okay weirdest animal in this chest oh
that's easy that's got to be the
platypus for sure
an echidna
an echidna
[Music]
australia is known for its unique
animals but nothing gets weirder than
these puppies i'm talking about
monotremes so how do we end up with them
i've tracked down echidna expert jane
fenelan
so i heard that when a british museum
employee first saw a platypus he thought
that was a prank oh completely he
apparently actually spent a long time
looking for the stitches he really
thought someone had taken like a mole or
a weasel and just stitched on a duck
beak to this animal he couldn't believe
that it was real and then you can
imagine when they found out they laid
eggs as well they didn't believe they
laid eggs for a long long time that was
just another level of weirdness they
just couldn't handle it they'd never
seen anything like it in their lives egg
laying isn't wildly shocking if you're a
reptile or a bird but monotremes are
mammals so why do they lay eggs they're
a bit of a mishmash of reptiles mammals
and uh just what we think the ancient
original mammals looked like we think
the original mammals did lay eggs so
that's they've just happened to retain
that i always just had an image of the
egg being like a chicken egg and
something you can crack the echidna and
platypus eggs are completely round and
they're also more leathery so it's just
more like a reptile eggs and you
actually you can't crack them as such
you have to actually tear them to get
them open it's very bizarre baby
echidnas weigh less than a gram so they
have some unique methods for getting
themselves out animals that lay eggs
need either an egg tooth to get out of
the egg which you could which they used
to tear the egg or they have a little
bony process on top of their noses
called a carruncle and which they use to
kind of like headbutt the egg to get out
that way
the ketos and platypus are the only
species that have both of those for some
reason they're just like one of those is
not enough to get out of this egg we
need to have both of them
and so we think that's what's happening
is they're kind of like head-butting and
then tearing with their teeth
and just like tearing a hole in this egg
and then coming out of it echidna
hatching is crazy but how they make
their babies is just as odd the kid
doesn't have four penises okay that'll
that's a showstopper an echidna penis is
quite elaborate as far as penises go it
has four heads it's like jurassic park
mixed with like frankenstein like they
just kind of mix together all the bits
so instead of having just one head at
the end they have four
and they've been described as rosette
glands almost like little flowers it
sounds prettier than it is but it's very
bizarre when you see it and close up
they do have like some little spines a
little bit as well it's about seven
centimeters long too so it's quite for
the size of the echidna it's quite long
so i have to ask why foreheads
particularly when males are competing
for females you do get this evolution of
various reproductive structures trying
to compete and one of the ways they can
compete is like trying to get these more
and more elaborate penises
and so that's why they can alternate
between the two sides because that means
they can like mate with one female and
then immediately turn around and make
with the other female by using the other
side it's one possibility we tend to
think of echidnas as land animals but in
another funny twist they like to swim
they don't get forced to but they'll
just quite voluntarily go out on a beach
go out into the ocean go around for a
swim and come back in again they seem to
just do it for fun to a certain extent
as well as just to cool down like us
they just like going for a swim as it
turns out there's an evolutionary reason
for this seemingly bizarre behavior i
think this was a little bit of a
surprise that
platypuses and echidnas
have a common ancestor only perhaps 30
or 40 million years ago
and that's estimated from molecular data
so taking long dna sequences and working
out how long ago those dna sequences
split so they've only evolved to be what
we've now considered to be echidnas
relatively recently so what makes
echidna such good swimmers they've got
this quite dorso eventually compressed
body form which is also typically a
assuming adaptation
they use their humerus to rotate it
makes them basically front wheel drive
and that front wheel drive style
locomotion also seems to have evolved
from them having swimming ancestors
they use that little kind of beak as a
snorkel and uh it's a curious looking
thing but um they're quite efficient at
it definitely they've got to take the
gold medal for australia's weirdest they
just seem to have so many weird
characteristics every time you think
you've found you know something about
them and like oh yeah that makes sense
you find something else weird so you i
was like oh egg laying and then i'm like
oh weird penis
[Music]
you